what's up guys so as you guys already
know GPU prices are insanely high what
used to be a two hundred dollar
mid-range 1060 GPU is now four hundred
dollars and picking up this same
graphics card is considered a great deal
and if steel if you're able to find it
anywhere in the three hundreds or even
two time periods so what happened but
before we start if you are interested in
one I think
Ram prices will go down then make sure
to click the link in the description
down below to check out what I have to
say about that many of you guys are very
irritated with the cryptocurrency miners
and think that they are the sole purpose
of this whole shortages occurring they
may have played a huge role in this
issue but I don't think they're
definitely the only reason in the past
year new gamers entering that PC gaming
scene has seen a huge increase and the
number of people operating has also
skyrocketed but to really surprise in a
cocky Winky
no matter what the cause right now we're
stuck with super high prices but when
will it go down well I don't want to be
the bearer of bad news but no one
actually knows many speculators haven't
seen that prices of these GPUs will go
down for many months now and only place
that is seeing them going down when
looking at it from a broad prospective
is up very high actually it really is
impossible to say when these will go
down the u.s. may decide to impose tax
codes on cryptocurrency
that could decrease the return on
investment of cryptocurrency not and
rendering it not nearly as good and this
could lead to many miners quitting and
cellular graphics cards this would lead
to a massive price drop at the same time
the US and other countries may not do
anything and this would keep the issue
thriving cryptocurrency itself could
crash or better method the utilizing
graphics cards may be discovered as a
result it really is very unstable and
not really possible pretty accurately
they may go up for a rest of the year or
even return to MSRP just next month so
what should you do if you're looking
into purchasing graphics card in my
opinion unless you have some really good
reason to get any graphics card right
now I recommend that you just wait and
see
and anything at least say $5,200 some
sporadic discounts or even a distant and
prices in the near future if you're a
professional who needs a GPU then and by
then I advise and use what you have
right now or look into the used market
paint your graphics cards are just mind
boggling if you're a gamer or a prison
on a tight budget and I recommend to
also get a use of graphics card or
snapchat gtx 1050 and a really good
discount overall at this point there's
not much that we can do other than wait
it out or just pay their price as a
result I recommend everyone try to wait
it out and as hopefully just hopefully a
the price will go down in the future
well guys that's all I have for you guys
this time make sure to post what you
guys are thinking the comments down
below
I read all my comments and I'm very
curious as to what you guys have to say
well guys that's all I have for you guys
this time if you liked this video make
sure to drop a like on this video if you
guys love it I would like to see more
videos just like this then make sure to
subscribe hit that Bell notification to
be notified whenever I post on your
video but that's all I have for you guys
this time until next video bye